sí
hola bienvenido de nuevo probablemente
habrás notado que las pelotas de ping
pong del simulador se asemejan más a la
arena que al agua por ejemplo las
pelotas apilan unas encima de las otras
nosotros usamos la simulación de esta
manera en buscando a dori por ejemplo la
arena en esta toma y la corriente de
australia oriental en esta otra
para crear una simulación más parecida
al agua necesitamos quitar el contorno
sólido a las pelotas no sólo rebotan
como pelotas de ping pong o sino que se
aprietan entre ellas para crear una
colisión suave las colisiones suaves son
lo más parecido a las fuerzas de presión
que el agua experimenta normalmente
existe un nombre sofisticado para este
tipo de simulación se le llama
hidrodinámica de partículas suavizadas o
sp h para abreviar hidrodinámica
literalmente significa el movimiento de
los líquidos ahora veamos cómo
interactúan grandes cantidades de
partículas suaves
usamos el parámetro llamado suavidad de
la colisión para controlar la manera en
la que las partículas colisionan
muy bien esto se está acercando bastante
otro parámetro que podemos controlar se
llama viscosidad la viscosidad es la
medición de qué tan fácil fluyen las
cosas
como vemos aquí los líquidos con baja
viscosidad como el agua fluyen con
considerable libertad
los líquidos con alta viscosidad como la
miel fluyen más lentamente como aquí
entre más partículas añadas serán
necesarios más cálculos y la respuesta
del programa será más lenta
este es un ejemplo de s&p h en buscando
a nemo se producen dentro de la boca de
una ballena aquí dibujamos las
partículas como pelotas para que puedas
observar su movimiento
en el siguiente ejercicio obtendrás un
poco de práctica experimentando con
estos parámetros para conseguir un
amplio rango de comportamientos así que
hasta pronto